the basic principle of Kashmir shaibism
is a strict non-dualism there is only
one unified reality the Supreme
Consciousness which is identical with
Shiva
Shiva is everything and thus everything
consists of and takes place within that
one consciousness
Shiva or Supreme Consciousness is one
for sure but he's also multiplicity and
one does not cancel out the other
the world is only this manifestation of
Shiva to his own awareness and through
his active power which is Shakti all of
these practices whether they be mantras
or meditation or bodily practice of
course have a single purpose of becoming
one with the infinite consciousness of
Shiva at this point one becomes what one
already was one becomes aware of the
all-encompassing nature of Shiva the
Supreme Consciousness from which through
which and in which all of reality
unfolds